let's talk about the three most
dangerous restaurant meals
in the world
now i know people will probably disagree
there's worse foods out there but these
are are pretty bad and they're very
dangerous so let's start with number one
and i'm not going to mention the
restaurant name you can figure this out
pretty easily okay the first one
pancakes hash browns
orange juice
and sausage okay for some of you that
might not know when you combine
sugar with a protein or this much
refined carbohydrate with protein
or even this much carbohydrate with fat
and it's heated
you're going to get a condition called
glycation now what is glycation
glycation is a condition where you bind
either fat to carb or protein to carb
and when you consume this you literally
clog up your arteries it messes with
your brain it gets lodged into the cells
and these proteins are damaged so
they're non-functional so they really
get in the way of normal function in
your body all right let's start with the
pancakes now the recipe for these
pancakes that this restaurant makes
they have to make them taste really good
so they're going to definitely put all
sorts of
things in it to make it taste better
definitely modified food starch which is
monosodium glutamate
it's not just wheat flour they put soy
flour which is really hard on the gut
of course you have the gluten
and then you have this refined
carbohydrate that's really high on the
glycemic index so it's going to spike
your blood sugar right away and of
course they add more food starch to this
and then you have hydrogenated soy which
is trans fats which is kind of like a
like a plastic food that's just going to
clog everything up and of course they do
have vitamins though they're fortified
with iron which is going to sit in your
stomach like lead okay you're going to
feel
very
bloated when you consume this
and
i mean i i don't understand
how people could even eat this without
completely passing out but
it's not just pancakes they put whipped
cream on it they put all this jelly on
it they put chocolate chips on there
marshmallow yeah marshmallows which
actually is a combination of modified
food starch and high fructose corn syrup
the that would be the worst ingredient
on the planet so that's just the
pancakes okay then the hashbrowns which
is very similar to a french fry
they put corn starch on there and they
add dextrose which is a synthetic sugar
and maltodextrin which is
way higher than glucose on the glycemic
index
and then of course you have the potato
and you cook all this and you fry it in
vegetable oil which is really not
vegetable oil it's grain oil
gmo glyphosate so you can have a product
that's so
tasty but very very
deadly for your arteries because you're
just going to spike the sugar and cause
the
pancreas to have whiplash then we have
juice which is orange juice which
actually has
no vitamins because it's pasteurized
there's no more vitamin c in there so
you're just drinking sugar water and
then on top of that we're going to have
to add the sausages right and it's not
just meat it's really bad processed meat
not organic and of course they add sugar
and msg to that meat to make it taste
really good you combine all this
together and you eat this i can't
believe anyone would not want to take a
serious
nap for at least several hours after
consuming this
but there are people that can just eat
this stuff
and somehow get away with it at least
initially now personally i was not that
bad but i was pretty bad
all right that's number one number two
this is a lunch food i'm not going to
mention the name you can figure it out
you have the burger fries coke and a
dessert
so of course on the burger you're not
just doing the patty you're doing the
bun right in the bun they have mold
inhibitors there's a refined
carbohydrate there's corn starch and of
course on the burger you're going to
have
maybe some bacon maybe you're going to
have ketchup right high fructose corn
syrup and then you can have mustard
which seems to be the only thing that
it's not going to be that bad for you
right so that's actually surprising
they'll have one or two things that
won't kill you and that would probably
be like a pickle or mustard right and
then we have the fries very similar
ingredients to the hash browns of course
they use hydrogenated soy which is trans
fats and then this highly refined potato
product which they're gonna they're
gonna deep fry so they're
putting the combination of sugar with
potato with all this fat under high
heats this is just wonderful for your
arteries
of course the coke that you drink has
high fructose corn syrup so you're going
to really spike your insulin and create
a lot of liver issues and insulin
resistance and then on top of that you
have to have a dessert right i mean
might as well just go completely over
the edge all right number three we have
the chicken fingers that so many
kids consume off the children's menu
which they use highly processed chicken
that is not free range
very high in omega-6 fatty acids
highly inflammatory and of course they
have the breading on there with the
chemicals and then it's all deep fried
so we have the soy oil the gmo
glyphosate crap with the msg to make it
taste good and it does taste good of
course you're not going to feel very
good after you consume it and then we
want to of course add the mac and cheese
we can't forget the mac and cheese right
which is basically highly refined pasta
with american cheese which by the way is
not even
cheese you can check out my video on
that i put a link down below so we just
add more refined carbs to the refined
carbs and the protein let's add a coke
to that let's add some more high
fructose corn syrup and a biscuit right
and this biscuit is made with corn
starch a lot of corn starch i don't even
think they actually put any wheat in it
but there's a lot of corn starch and
corn or soy hydrogenated oils okay
and of course that is heated more
glycation so this is a recipe for
disaster for your heart
this is why a lot of children are
developing a fatty liver this is why
over 50 to 60 to 70 percent of the
population is going right towards
pre-diabetes and diabetes this is why
the great majority of the population has
metabolic syndrome high blood pressure
obesity dementia frequent urination
especially at night and the list goes on
and on and on now if you have a more
deadly or dangerous meal that you want
to share down below put it down below i
want to check it out
so if you're enjoying my content which i
hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to
your health
and you have a success i would really
appreciate you sharing your success
story so click the link down below to my
website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire
others